Bonjour tout le monde
et bienvenue dans un nouveau podcast
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de parler
de l'intelligence artificielle
j'ai déjà pardon
parlé plusieurs fois de l'intelligence artificielle
j'ai notamment fait une vidéo sur
comment utiliser chat GPT pour
aider à apprendre une langue
mais voilà
aujourd'hui j'avais envie de parler de l'intelligence
artificielle
d'une autre manière
en fait cette année
quand j'ai pris la décision de changer de travail
pour devenir professeur de français
je me suis posé beaucoup de questions
par rapport à l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un sujet qui est très d'actualité en ce moment
parce que d'un côté on a des difficultés économiques
un peu dans tous les pays
typiquement des questions sur l'inflation
et de l'autre on voit les
entreprises d'intelligence artificielle
les sociétés d'IA
battrent des records
et avoir des valorisations boursières
toujours plus élevées
les jours après les autres
donc d'un côté
les citoyens ont du mal économiquement avec l'inflation
et de l'autre la bourse bat des records
donc on ne va pas aujourd'hui parler de macro-économie
mais c'est je pense à un sujet qui
à la fois révolutionne notre vie
mais qui en même temps amène beaucoup d'inquiétude
et ce pour un peu tout le monde
en gros la question qu'on se pose tous en ce moment
c'est est-ce que l'IA va remplacer mon métier
est-ce que l'IA va remplacer
mon travail, est-ce que l'IA
va nous remplacer
et je trouvais ça intéressant parce que bon
j'en ai discuté plusieurs fois en cours
avec des élèves
mais c'est aussi
des questions que je me suis posé
au moment de prendre la décision
de devenir professeur de français
et créateur de contenu
la 1ère question que je me posais
mais celle-ci je vais y répondre rapidement
c'est de savoir
est-ce que les gens vont toujours avoir envie
d'apprendre des langues
en sachant qu'on a de plus en plus de traduction
automatique que ce soit sur internet
ou même dans la vraie vie maintenant
maintenant
vous pouvez utiliser Google
traduction pour dire quelque chose dans une langue
le traduire et le faire écouter
et on peut s'imaginer que dans le futur
avec l'intelligence artificielle
on aura des outils de traduction
en live
en direct avec les personnes avec lesquelles on parle
cette question je vais y répondre rapidement
puisque je l'ai déjà traité dans d'autres podcasts
mais en gros
je pense que même si le nombre de personnes
qui vont apprendre des langues étrangères
risque de diminuer
je pense qu'il y aura toujours
un intérêt à cet apprentissage
notamment parce que ça ouvre des portes sur la culture
d'un pays
c'est aussi un bon exercice
pour notre mémoire
pour notre intelligence entre guillemets
donc je pense qu'il y aura toujours des personnes
pour apprendre des langues
mais maintenant je me suis posé deux autres questions
enfin plusieurs autres questions
sur
ce changement de métier
sur mon envie de changer de métier pour devenir
professeur de français
en fait quand j'ai décidé de devenir professeur
j'apprenais déjà moi-même des langues
j'apprenais en autodidacte
j'apprenais tout seul le japonais notamment
et du coup même à titre personnel
je ne ressentais pas vraiment le besoin
de prendre des cours
avec un professeur
j'avais beaucoup d'outils ...
j'avais beaucoup d'outils disponibles
pardon
et
je les utilisais
de manière je pense efficace et du coup
ça diminuait mon besoin d'avoir un professeur
de japonais typiquement chat GPT
dès que j'avais une question sur de la grammaire
j'ai envoyé un message à Chat GPT
je lui demandais de me donner des exemples
et ça convenait parfaitement à mon besoin
donc sur l'aspect professeur de langue
déjà je me disais mais est-ce que les gens
auront
vraiment besoin d'avoir des professeurs de langue
et après sur la création de contenu
quand j'ai décidé de devenir
professeur de français et créateur de contenu
j'ai commencé à regarder
ce qui se faisait pardon
sur TikTok Instagram
et YouTube et là j'ai vu
j'ai très rapidement vu des vidéos
générées par IA
qui étaient des vidéos dans un français simple
dans un français lent
sur des sujets assez communs
un peu comme ce que je fais là
sauf que c'était des voix robotiques
et c'était entièrement générées par ia
et en fait en voyant ça je me suis dit mais
juste en faisant un prompt avec chat GPT
je peux facilement créer ce genre de vidéo
très rapidement
et du coup est-ce que ça sert toujours à quelque chose
d'avoir un créateur de contenu
qui fait ce genre de podcast
et ce qui demande plus de travail
plus de travail pour filmer
plus de travail pour éditer la vidéo
pour monter la vidéo
pour ensuite la poster
et du coup sur ces 2 constats
quand j'ai commencé à me m'intéresser à ce sujet
j'ai eu plein de questions
est-ce qu'on va toujours avoir besoin de
professeur de langue
à quoi ça sert de payer des cours
individuels si on peut accéder à tout gratuitement
et facilement avec chat GPT
quelle va être la place des créateurs de contenu
sur YouTube ou sur les autres plateformes
pourquoi s'embêter à produire du contenu
si on peut créer plus facilement
je lis mes notes
est-ce que ce genre de contenu est plus ou moins
efficace pour l'apprentissage des langues
même pour les étudiants
on parle souvent de contenu idéal
quand on apprend une langue
il faut s'immerger dans la langue
il faut écouter
il faut regarder du contenu dans la langue
et le contenu idéal
c'est un contenu qui correspond
parfaitement à votre niveau
c'est-à-dire qui n'est ni trop facile
ni trop difficile
et qui correspond à vos centres d'intérêt
et pour ça l'intelligence artificielle est très forte
elle répond parfaitement à ce besoin
du coup
est-ce que avoir un créateur de contenu comme ce que je
je fais maintenant
est-ce que c'est toujours utile
et du coup pour résumer
les 2 questions c'était
est-ce qu'un professeur de français est toujours utile
est-ce qu'un créateur de contenu est toujours utile
et du coup la question de cette vidéo
est-ce que l'intelligence artificielle
va me remplacer
plus généralement nous remplacer
pour ce qui est du professeur
du métier de professeur
je pense qu'il y a plusieurs points
premièrement
quand on prend un cours pardon avec un professeur
on accède à de la connaissance
le professeur nous donne de la connaissance
ça c'est quelque chose qui a déjà été
révolutionné par l'arrivée d'internet
avec l'arrivée d'internet maintenant on peut apprendre
quasiment tout et n'importe quoi
gratuitement et librement
il y a des cours de l'université d'Harvard par exemple
entièrement disponible sur internet
vous pouvez apprendre n'importe quelle langue
gratuitement sur internet et j'insiste là-dessus
et du coup l'IA
elle n'a pas vraiment
inventer cet accès à la connaissance
ce que l'IA a révolutionné
c'est en fait la manière dont on recherche
cette connaissance
avant quand on recherchait quelque chose sur internet
selon le sujet si c'est plus ou moins spécifique
ça pouvait être
très difficile de trouver les bonnes informations
au bon endroit
du coup ça demande de la recherche
et ça demande de structurer les résultats qu'on trouve
de structurer les informations qu'on trouve
et pour ça Chat GPT et n'importe quelle
intelligence artificielle
est très bon
c'est-à-dire que vous allez demander à Chat GPT
et il va vous faire le travail de recherche et de
synthèse
très rapidement
et de manière très propre finalement
donc
l'intelligence artificielle
n'a pas vraiment révolutionné
notre accès à la connaissance
je pense que c'est plutôt internet
qui a révolutionné notre accès à la connaissance
mais il facilite grandement
enfin l'intelligence artificielle
elle facilite grandement
cette consommation
de connaissance sur internet
on a plus besoin de chercher dans plein de sites
différents, le contenu
les connaissances qu'il nous faut
on peut demander à Chat GPT
et il nous répond rapidement
donc
j'ai envie de dire que sur l'aspect connaissance
Chat GPT va
rivaliser en fait avec un professeur de langue
puisqu'il va pouvoir donner de l'information
structurée
aux étudiants aux apprenants de langue
et ensuite après il y a tout ce qui est pédagogie
la pédagogie c'est la science
d'enseigner quelque chose
c'est pour faciliter l'apprentissage des élèves
en gros quand vous prenez des cours de langue
ce que vous souhaitez
c'est de progresser le plus efficacement possible
et ça le professeur il a un gros rôle à jouer puisque
selon son expérience
il va pouvoir s'adapter à l'élève
il va pouvoir s'adapter à vous
typiquement si
je fais un rapide exemple
j'ai parfois des élèves qui sont très euh
qui veulent vraiment faire de la discussion
qui sont dans un apprentissage très naturel
on parle
et ils apprennent comme ça un peu sur le tas
entre guillemets
et de l'autre côté
il y a des élèves qui sont
qui ont une approche beaucoup plus théorique
c'est-à-dire que
ils vont avoir besoin de voir les règles de grammaire
pour apprendre précisément la langue
et ça c'est aussi un travail du professeur
c'est de s'adapter aux besoins
c'est d'avoir conscience
qu'il y a plusieurs profils d'élèves
et s'adapter le mieux possible aux besoins de l'élève
ça pour l'instant
j'ai l'impression que l'intelligence artificielle
est un peu limitée dans le sens où Chat GPT
j'ai l'impression que
les réponses de Chat GPT restent assez générales
il s'adapte en partie à votre niveau
à ce que vous voulez apprendre
mais
c'est les messages
qu'il envoie sont toujours un peu plat
c'est jamais vraiment
il ne cherche
on a pas l'impression qu'il nous comprend vraiment
quand vous avez un professeur
l'idée
c'est vraiment de voilà que la personne en face
ressente si vous êtes démotivé
si vous manquez de motivation
ou si vous sentez bloqué à un endroit
et ça c'est quelque chose que
pour l'instant Chat GPT
ne rivalise pas vraiment
avec les professeurs de langue
donc d'un côté
un cours de langue individuel
c'est cher ça coûte de l'argent
mais de l'autre
je pense que ça a toujours de la valeur ajoutée
par rapport à un apprentissage comme Chat GPT
comme un apprentissage avec l'intelligence artificielle
pour ma part comme j'apprends le japonais
le portugais et un petit peu le coréen
en fait je suis dans la position de l'étudiant
et je sais ce que c'est que d'apprendre une langue
et du coup je ressens les difficultés
même si je n'ai pas appris le français de la même façon
j'ai eu un apprentissage naturel du français
c'est ma langue maternelle
même si je n'ai pas eu cet apprentissage
naturel du français (I mean the opposite lol)
je comprends
les difficultés que peuvent avoir des étudiants
en apprenant le français
par exemple sur la prononciation
les étudiants vont avoir du mal à prononcer les R
par exemple les étudiants japonais notamment
et pour ma part quand j'ai
appris quand j'ai commencé à apprendre un petit peu le
mandarin j'avais beaucoup de mal à
prononcer les mots
donc ça
cette expérience me permet de me mettre à la place
des étudiants
et c'est quelque chose que je pense
Chat GPT
ou n'importe quelle intelligence artificielle
va encore avoir du mal à faire
et ensuite sur la partie création de contenu
là je suis peut-être un peu plus pessimiste
ce que je vais dire
ça s'applique aussi à la création musicale
mais en fait ce que j'ai l'impression
c'est que quand on fait des choses assez basiques
assez mainstream comme ce que je fais là ce podcast
ce n'est pas vraiment très difficile
à réaliser ce n'est pas très original on va dire
je pense que c'est quelque chose que
Chat GPT peut faire enfin
les modèles
d'intelligence artificielle peuvent remplacer
assez facilement
et du coup les questions que je me pose c'est
qu'est-ce que va devenir toute cette partie de
création de contenu
si je suis encore plus pessimiste en fait je me demande
qu'est-ce que va devenir la musique
qu'on écoute en général
et aussi par exemple les films
est-ce que un jour
il y aura un film entièrement généré par IA
et le pire ça serait que ce soit un bon film
donc sur cette partie pour l'instant
j'avoue j'ai un peu du mal à voir ce que ça va donner
je vois déjà les TikTok
faits automatiquement par
IA qui parle lentement en français
je pense que ça peut être un outil
un bon outil pour votre apprentissage
mais il y a toujours cette voix robotique
et le fait que ce soit pas vraiment humain derrière
ça enlève un peu de
je sais pas de l'intérêt
de l'essence d'apprendre une langue
donc pour ma part
j'ai un peu envie de dire que j'essaierai
forcément toujours
d'écouter de la musique
qui a été créée par un être humain
de toujours
regarder un film qui a été créé par un être humain
parce que c'est ça qui donne le grain
artistique c'est ça qui donne
des émotions etc
alors que si
quand c'est généré purement par intelligence
artificielle
on peut facilement se dire
c'est un algorithme qui
a essayé de nous faire ressentir ça
ça etc
pour ce qui est du contenu purement pédagogique
comme les vidéos de
français où on parle lentement comme ce podcast
là j'ai un peu plus de mal à savoir
idem pour tout ce qui est divertissement
Entertainment
j'ai du mal à savoir à quel point
on va continuer à faire nous-même du contenu
et à quel point ce sera toujours valorisé
entre guillemets pardon
ce genre de contenu
fait par des humains
donc en soi voilà je pense que dans tous les cas
l'intelligence artificielle va avoir un énorme impact
sur mon métier sur le métier de professeur de français
sur le métier de créateur de contenu
j'ai encore du mal à savoir ce que ça va donner
je suis à la fois optimiste et à la fois pessimiste
c'est un peu une réponse nulle mais
je n'ai pas encore d'avis vraiment précis
j'aime ce que je fais
et je suis convaincu que ce que je fais
ça peut être utile
pour des personnes qui apprennent le français
et donc c'est ça qui me fait continuer
si c'était purement par opportunisme
je pense que j'arrêterai peut-être de faire ça
mais voilà c'était un peu ma réflexion sur
l'apprentissage des langues
le métier de professeur et de créateur de contenu
et aussi les bouleversements
les changements qui vont arriver
avec l'intelligence artificielle
j'espère que ce podcast vous aura plu
si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à soutenir en mettant un like
et un commentaire
et également si vous voulez parler de votre propre
expérience dans les commentaires
n'hésitez pas à parler
voilà de votre travail et savoir ce que vous en pensez
vis-à-vis de l'intelligence artificielle
voilà j'espère que ce podcast vous aura plu
et je vous dis à la prochaine